bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados
de eeuu a argentina de turquía australia
de alemania a pakistán en todo el mundo
los precios han subido como la espuma un
fenómeno que se conoce como la inflación
a qué se debe quienes son los más
afectados y qué están haciendo los
gobiernos para contrarrestarlo
comencemos con definiciones simples la
inflación es la subida de los precios de
bienes y servicios en un periodo
determinado por contra cuando los
precios bajan hablamos de deflación pero
esto no suele ocurrir con frecuencia los
problemas inflacionarios solían afectar
a los países de manera individual pero
con una crisis como la causada por la
pandemia y con economías cada vez más
interconectadas ahora se trata de un
fenómeno global
tradicionalmente existen dos causas la
inflación por demanda y la inflación por
costos
la primera se da cuando como su nombre
lo indica la demanda supera la capacidad
de la economía para producir o importar
productos lo que también se conoce como
la oferta con la pandemia muchos
gobiernos optaron por ofrecer grandes
estímulos fiscales para mantener a flote
a sus ciudadanos durante la peor fase de
la emergencia sanitaria muchos
recibieron cheques del gobierno y ante
la situación decidieron ahorrar pero con
la llegada de la reactivación económica
llegó también el momento de gastar y por
otro lado está la inflación por costos
que se da cuando suben los precios de
las materias primas por ejemplo el
petróleo está cotizando en máximos en
medio de la escalada militar entre rusia
y ucrania es una subida de precios que
impacta directamente en el costo del
transporte de los productos a nivel
mundial y si sube el precio de los
insumos de producción en las empresas
trasladan estos costos extra a los
consumidores para proteger así sus
márgenes de ganancia
y es exactamente lo que ha ocurrido con
la llamada crisis de la cadena de
suministros que ha interrumpido el flujo
de los productos
imaginemos que queremos comprar un
automóvil nuevo para producirlos se
necesitan partes y componentes desde
chips electrónicos hasta el caucho para
las llantas
si todo sube aumentará el costo final
del vehículo y quien pagará por ello
adivinaron ustedes y yo o sea los
consumidores
es por eso que cuando vamos al
supermercado compramos un televisor o
llenamos el tanque de nuestro automóvil
sentimos ese peso directamente en
nuestro bolsillo y quiénes son los más
afectados por el proceso inflacionario
principalmente las familias de menos
recursos que ven como ya su reducido
poder adquisitivo disminuye cada vez más
para medir la inflación en los países
usan el llamado índice de precios al
consumidor el ipc está compuesto por una
canasta con productos y servicios de los
que mide cuánto ha subido o bajado el
precio en un periodo determinado por
ejemplo en alemania en octubre los
ciudadanos llegaron a pagar un 18% más
por los combustibles que en octubre de
2020 en pakistán en enero de 2022 las
familias pagaron un 13% más por los
alimentos que en enero de 2021 y en
brasil en enero la comida fue un 8% más
cara que un año antes en la actualidad
los brasileños gastan en promedio un 15
por ciento de su presupuesto en
alimentación algo que se eleva para el
25 por ciento para las familias de muy
bajos ingresos pero la inflación golpea
también a las grandes potencias eeuu
registró en enero de 2022 una tasa
interanual del 7,5 por ciento la mayor
en cuatro décadas
eso quiere decir que los precios de
enero estuvieron en promedio 75 por
ciento más caros que hace exactamente un
año y que están haciendo los gobiernos
para controlar la inflación mucha de la
responsabilidad recae sobre los bancos
centrales instituciones públicas que
controlan la oferta monetaria en los
países en las economías avanzadas la
crisis del 2008 llevó a los bancos
centrales a llevar dichas tasas a
mínimos históricos y en la pandemia la
mayoría de los bancos centrales del
mundo redujeron sus tasas lo que más
pudieron para fomentar el consumo y
mover en la economía eso logró que la
recuperación tardará menos de lo
previsto pero con más dinero en los
bolsillos de los ciudadanos la demanda
de bienes y servicios aumentó a un ritmo
mucho más acelerado que la oferta
ejerciendo presión sobre los precios y
cuando la inflación se sale de control a
la mejor herramienta de los bancos
centrales es subir las tasas del interés
por ejemplo en eeuu la reserva federal
anunció que aumentará los tipos de
interés subirlos es sinónimo de
encarecer los préstamos esto afecta
créditos hipotecarios préstamos de libre
inversión y hasta los pagos con tarjeta
de crédito de esta manera se forzará el
dinero en circulación y esto forzaría
una bajada de los precios generales
un caso que llama la atención es el de
turquía
allí los precios al consumidor en enero
de 2022 eran 48 6% más caros que hace un
año la tasa más alta en 20 años sin
embargo el presidente recep tayip
erdogán yendo en contra de las
recomendaciones de los expertos y de la
tendencia mundial se niega a subir las
tasas de interés y por el contrario ha
presionado grandes descensos en las
mismas lo que ha provocado además el
colapso de la moneda local la lira una
herida autoinfligida cuando de inflación
se trata esto ha impactado también
directamente en la popularidad del líder
de turno y en sus posibilidades de
reelegirse en 2023
y aunque según muchos expertos el
fenómeno inflacionario global es
transitorio le corresponde a los
gobiernos controlarlo y evitar que se
vuelva permanente ya que una alza
generalizada y prolongada en los precios
de los bienes básicos sólo traerá más
descontento social y más retos para la
estabilidad de los países si le sirvió
el vídeo para entender las razones
detrás de la inflación mundial los
esperamos en otro episodio de en cinco
minutos en france 24 y france24 puntocom